багато дітей в українському навчаються онлайн
на жаль сотень тисяч з них не мають
ноутбуки планшет чи належного інтернету
ми шукали спос, щоб ДТІ могли
продовжувати онлайн заняття Та сваті
нати п годину вни цифро началь центри
створюють у потерпілих у громадах
де Уч переважно навчаються дистанцій а
бш шл закритий для очних зайняти DLC
для та протей цін ноутбуки планшети та
найінтернет також у центрах ПТО менто Я
залюбки допоможуть наш менто залучають
дітей до навчання через Гру створюють
гуртки допомагають старшим тям
готуватися до ісв це це яке вт
безтурботно для дітей Куди хоче приходи
знову Як знай DLC поруч з вами ми створ
цент потерпілих у громадах перти за
м посиланням щоб знай найближче до вас
Амаль інформа звір на сайт за полан DLC
безко доступ розум школярам